[Applause]
and the Oscar goes too
Deborah L Scott for Titanic
[Music]
thank you very much the academy I'm
deeply honored to accept this award on
the behalf of David LaVey Beth
coningsburg Lolly poor Matt reitzman
Dale wibbon Dominic Girardi Jean gold
and the rest of my remarkable costume
crew their dedication Talent friendship
and guidance helped fulfill my dream to
bring the spirit of Titanic and her
passengers to life thank you Jim Cameron
for the first class passage thanks John
Landau and Ray sankini for such fine
navigation for my parents my husband and
finally my two daughters Tess and Hannah
whose Beauty Is My Greatest Inspiration
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]